um that's an interesting example come
back to the problem we drove here
one of X what domain will work for our
parabola after that what matters X can I
put into that an answer is unlike this
guy right you can put it anything you'd
like right you can put in any value of x
so the way would say that is the domain
for this guy so just go back to where
you treat your problem right the debate
for this is all values of X sometimes
you will see in textbooks again a little
bit of read notation here I'll just
quickly show you what it is and what it
means sometimes you see this X a
funny-looking e which is in fact not an
e it's an epsilon which is the fifth
Greek letter and then you'll see an R
which has an extra line on the end okay
what that means is X can be any real
number which is for our intents and
purposes the same as saying although
he's of X if you see this this is what
it means if you want to be super techy
you can write it if you like but if you
do want to write it you probably want to
come and talk to me later to get a
proper definition of it because it's a
cool idea just not we didn't discover
the course okay
all right so that's to me let's think
about I want to do another example for
domain
we've been dealing with square roots for
a long time like since my taggers phase
right we know what square roots up what
does the square root of x look like as a
graph I can plot some points kind of
let's try x equals 0 does that work is
it this zero have a square root the
answer is it does the square root of
zero is just zero that's the number you
squared you get here
so there's zero zero it's a point one
what's the square root of 1 1 I'm gonna
pick some nice stuff is to help me out
here how about the square root of 4 and
that's the next one square root of 4 is
2 okay now help me out here I'm gonna go
1 2 3 4 and they're not bigger one two
so there's my point we'll do one more
cuz I'm gonna round of space in a second
what would you like to suggest is
another value to put it that's just so
hard why do this why how about 9 8 9 2
squared on bottom the square root of 9
is 3 ok so if I go that's 4 5 6 7 8 9 3
so got a point like that okay now if I
join these up can you see it's going up
but it's slowing down see that right it
looks like this in fact if you turn your
head sideways you'll notice it looks
kind of like a parabola a lot of quick
since we'll talk about that next week
okay yeah this is the square root of x
can you see it's a function right that's
a function that you're happy with the
fact there's a function how do I don't I
slapped my vertical line on their
vertical line test and everywhere I go
intersects only once right yeah
correct it's exactly right if there's
only a single spot on there where
there's another value that it's not a
function because every input every
employee can only have one out okay now
now that we have this graph I wonder if
you can tell me what the domain is what
values of X work in contrast to those
that don't fantastic
I can put any positive values in there I
can't put negative ones in there all
right but we're almost there there's
actually some tiny thing that's missing
off of this in fact it's the first value
that I tried it was zero so in fact zero
is okay zero is what I would say in the
domain it's an x value that I can put it
at it's alright so to indicate that I
put in that little equality sign
underneath my feet upon my X is greater
or equal to zero now these two examples
here when you get X on the denominator
or when you get X under the square root
they're the two important ones for now
where domain has to be watched out for
okay I'm actually not gonna move on to
rage it because it's a little more so
far we've been grasping these and making
an argument from there but I wonder if
you could help me work out if these are
a little trickier how to work out domain
without drawing the field because
drawing this time consuming right can I
avoid it let's think yeah here's another
example let's think about this guy now I
don't want you to draw it don't want you
to draw I purposely do not want you to
draw I do want to ask you that
what kind of a shape is this likely to
me what family of graphs is it in do you
see it's still kind of like this it's
not quadratic right cubic it's not a
it's not one of these guys it's got an X
on the denominator right so to find out
where this thing breaks what's the value
to avoid what value our do I need to
avoid I don't want the denominator to be
0 ok what's the denominator 0 it
explodes right so that's value I'm
trying to steer clear off so I'm gonna
say the asymptotes that's the value I
need to avoid in this case right it's
when sorry it's when the denominator
that's the denominator it's where the
denominator 0 right that's when things
are going to break down for me
ok but that's just a it's just an
equation I can solve this right so can
you help me up what I do to X I'll add 3
to both sides and then all divine ok so
we go x equals t o2 is where the
asymptote is now I knew where the domain
is right the domain is everywhere else
right I can be less than the asymptote
to the left or I could be to the right
do you see that you care that I can be
to the left I can be to right I just
can't be on there exactly and I'll be
fine ok let's have a look at this one
okay again this is under the square root
okay so example 4 and they don't get
should pack up let's do this five six
now I have a look over here right what
will make this function what will make
it break one of the things I need to
employ it it's negative values of the
problem are they negative values in the
problem if what's underneath the square
root is negative you put in your
calculator and it'll say forget it I'm
going home it doesn't work okay
so therefore what's on this square root
here is different it's 5 minus X ok so
it's not an asymptote it's ok it's to
avoid these are the knives I don't want
to put in and I'm writing that to
clarify I'm not working at the domain
right now I'm working at the opposite of
the domain
so I want this thing five take away X
that's the thing on the denominator what
were the causing the problems again it's
negatives right negatives so messed a
zebra yeah and I solve this I'll deal
with the numbers first so I can't that
five over to the other side negative
five right now that's a minus xi-1 of
minus X day what am I gonna do now
I should divide or multiply same thing
by negative one right now what's out
here I'm some of you guys would might
remember this but when you multiply both
sides by a negative number you have to
flip the inequality right like this now
by the way just quickly why like that's
a bit random like why do you do that
answer because you have to make things
make things make sense reasons I'm
pretty sure two is less than three right
pretty sure check on your calculator if
you like but if I multiply both sides by
minus one right is negative two less
than negative 3
and the answer is no negative three is
more negative that's why the inequality
flips around so now I have this X is
greater than 5 that's the values I need
to avoid less you
these are the bad ones so therefore
what's the domain the domain is um the
domain is everything else right if X is
greater than 5 is bad then what I want
is X is less than or equal to 5
those values are okay these aren't too
bad avoid them these ones are good now
because I will help you with this one
what does this thing actually look like
I'll show you see how you got the shape
going off to the right
this shape it goes off to the left right
I know it for two reasons number one
because the domain says so X is gonna be
less than or equal to 5 I also know cuz
this - if there's things around